Hello everyone and before today's show, I have incredibly exciting news for you about a live show. On Friday the 4th of September, Dominic and I will be at the South Bank to do something that we have not done before. So you will be the first people to hear it. We are telling the story of what is the ultimate Victorian adventure. The date is 1868, the location. is Abyssinia and the Emperor of Abyssinia has been writing letters to Queen Victoria who rather rudely has not replied to them. So the Emperor of Abyssinia, annoyed about this, has kidnapped a number of British subjects. In response, Britain sends an expedition to rescue the captives and it is no exaggeration to say it is massive. On this expedition, 13,000 soldiers, 40,000 animals, including 44 elephants, and the British even put down a railway line to transport everything. It's an incredible story full of jaw-dropping events, ludicrous characters, lots of moustaches,
大家好，在今天的节目开始之前，我有一个关于现场演出的重磅好消息要告诉大家。9月4日星期五，多米尼克和我将前往南岸艺术中心，去做一件我们从未做过的事情。所以你们将是第一批听到这个消息的人。我们将讲述一个终极维多利亚时代的冒险故事。时间是1868年，地点是阿比西尼亚，阿比西尼亚皇帝一直在给维多利亚女王写信，而女王却非常无礼地没有回复。于是，对此感到恼火的阿比西尼亚皇帝绑架了多名英国臣民。作为回应，英国派出了一支远征军去营救人质，毫不夸张地说，这支队伍规模极其庞大。在这支远征军中，有13000名士兵、40000头牲畜，其中包括44头大象，英国人甚至铺设了一条铁路线来运输物资。这是一个令人难以置信的故事，充满了令人瞠目结舌的事件、荒谬的人物、大量的胡子，
lots of general Victorian shenanigans. And as I say, it is the first time that we have ever done it on The Restless History. I don't want to blow our trumpet, but I think it's going to be. an absolute Rest is History classic. So if you want to get a ticket for the ultimate Victorian adventure at the South Bank in London on Friday the 4th of September, you know where to go. The rest is history.com. Having this day my horse, my hand, my lance guided so well that I obtained the prize both by the judgment of the English eyes and of some sent from that sweet enemy France, Horseman, my skill in horsemanship advance. Town folks, my strength. A daintier judge applies his
以及各种典型的维多利亚时代的闹剧。正如我所说，这是我们第一次在《历史的余味》中尝试这种形式。我不想自吹自擂，但我认为这绝对会成为《历史的余味》的经典之作。所以，如果你想购买9月4日星期五在伦敦南岸艺术中心举行的终极维多利亚时代冒险演出的门票，你知道该去哪里。therestisistory.com。这一天，我的马、我的手、我的长矛引导得如此之好，以至于我获得了奖项，无论是通过英国人的眼光，还是通过那些来自甜蜜敌人法国的使者的评判，骑手们，我的骑术技巧得到了提升。镇上的人们，我的力量。一位更挑剔的评判将他的
praise to skill which from good use doth rise. Some lucky wits impute it but to chance. Others, because of both sides I do take my blood from them who did excel in this, think nature me a man of arms did make. How far they shot awry. The true causes, Stella looked on, and from her heavenly face sent forth the beams which made so fair my race. So that is a lovely sonnet. It was written in May 1581 by Philip Sidney, who was the golden boy of the court of Queen Elizabeth I. Now, in 1581, the skies are dark. Beyond the limits of England, blood is flowing. The civil war in France. There are cities on fire in the low countries in modern day Belgium and Holland. There are bodies drifting down the Dutch canals.
赞美给予了因善用而提升的技巧。一些幸运的聪明人将其归因于运气。其他人，因为我从那些擅长此道的人那里继承了血统，认为大自然造就了我这个武士。他们错得有多离谱。真正的原因是，斯特拉注视着我，从她那如天堂般的面容中射出的光芒，成就了我如此辉煌的竞赛。所以，这是一首可爱的十四行诗。它写于1581年5月，作者是菲利普·西德尼，他是伊丽莎白一世女王宫廷里的宠儿。现在，在1581年，天空是阴暗的。在英国国界之外，鲜血正在流淌。法国的内战。低地国家，即今天的比利时和荷兰，城市正在燃烧。尸体顺着荷兰的运河漂流而下。
And in Spain, the sinister figure of Philip II is brooding on the exploits, the piratical exploits, he would call them, of Francis Drake and he's plotting his revenge on England. But in Whitehall, that day in May 1581, the court of Elizabeth I first has never glittered more brightly because they're holding a tournament. Elizabeth is there, the great nobles are there, MSs from France are there, and the big star of the show is this guy, Philip Sidney, the man who wrote those words.
在西班牙，菲利普二世这个阴险的人物正在沉思弗朗西斯·德雷克的功绩——他会称之为海盗行径——并策划着对英国的报复。但在白厅，1581年5月的那一天，伊丽莎白一世的宫廷从未如此光彩夺目，因为他们正在举行一场锦标赛。伊丽莎白在那里，伟大的贵族们在那里，来自法国的使节们也在那里，而这场演出的主角就是这个人，菲利普·西德尼，那个写下这些文字的人。
He has won the prize. He has cut a dash and captured the hearts and minds of the watching spectators. The match report of the tournament then proceeded Master Philip Sidney in very sumptuous manner, with armor part blue and the rest gilt and engraven, with four spare horses having comparisons
他赢得了奖项。他风度翩翩，俘获了在场观众的心。锦标赛的比赛报告随后写道：菲利普·西德尼爵士以极其华丽的方式出场，身穿部分蓝色、其余部分镀金并刻有花纹的盔甲，带着四匹备用马，配有
and furniture very rich and costly. So Tom Phillips, Sydney, he's a tremendous man, isn't he? Yeah, he's the embodiment, I think, of everything that a Renaissance courtier dreams of being. And that's why he's such a superstar. So he is insanely well connected. He's the nephew in the air of the Earl of Leicester, Robert Dudley, Elizabeth I, great favourite. And he is the brother-in-law of the Earl of Pembroke, who builds this tremendous house outside Wilton in Wiltshire and the Salisbury area. Love it to have Wilshire in the Salisbury area back on the show. It has these beautiful Tudor Gardens in Blackadder.
非常昂贵且华丽的马具。那么汤姆，菲利普·西德尼，他是个了不起的人，不是吗？是的，我认为他是文艺复兴时期廷臣梦想成为的一切的化身。这就是为什么他是一位超级巨星。他的人脉极其广泛。他是莱斯特伯爵罗伯特·达德利的侄子和继承人，而罗伯特·达德利是伊丽莎白一世最宠爱的人。他还是彭布罗克伯爵的妹夫，彭布罗克伯爵在威尔特郡威尔顿外和索尔兹伯里地区建造了这座宏伟的宅邸。很高兴能再次在节目中提到索尔兹伯里地区的威尔特郡。它有《黑爵士》中那些美丽的都铎式花园。
When Blackadder falls in love with Bob and they go walking into the tune of Green Sleeves, it's the gardens of Wilton House that you see. So that's very much Sydney's kind of house in the country. He has a European reputation as well as an English one. He's famous across the continent for his intellect, for his eloquence, for his courtesy. He's kind of the model of spretzatura, this kind of Italian ideal of nonchalant style. And he is one of the great geniuses of this golden age of English literature that flourishes in the reign of Elizabeth I. So that sonnet that you read is part of a sequence that, in the opinion of most critics rank second only to the sonnet sequence written by Shakespeare himself. The sonnet sequence is called Astrophil and Stella. And Stella is a star, and Astrophil is star lover. But of course, Phil is a play on Philip Sidney's own name.
当黑爵士爱上鲍勃，他们伴随着《绿袖子》的曲调散步时，你看到的就是威尔顿庄园的花园。所以这非常符合西德尼在乡下的那种宅邸风格。他在欧洲和英国都享有盛誉。他以才华、口才和礼貌闻名于整个欧洲大陆。他是“sprezzatura”（一种意大利式的漫不经心风格）的典范。他是伊丽莎白一世统治时期英国文学黄金时代的天才之一。你读的那首十四行诗是一个系列的一部分，大多数评论家认为，该系列仅次于莎士比亚本人创作的十四行诗系列。这个系列被称为《爱星者与星》。斯特拉是星星，而爱星者是星星的爱人。当然，“Phil”是菲利普·西德尼名字的谐音。
What can I say? The Elizabethans love these kind of puns and word plays. He's also the author of a very famous defense of poetry, which again has a kind of Europe-wide reputation. And he's written a poem called Arcadia, which is a pastoral romance. He wrote it at Wilton House and he dedicated it to his sister, the countess of Pembroke. And the most famous line from that poem, they are never alone that are accompanied with noble thoughts, very stirring and inspiring. And Sydney can get away with writing this kind of stuff because everyone takes for granted that this is exactly what he is about. He is, I think,
我能说什么呢？伊丽莎白时代的人喜欢这种双关语和文字游戏。他还是非常著名的《诗辩》的作者，这本书在欧洲也享有盛誉。他还写了一首名为《阿卡迪亚》的诗，这是一部田园浪漫史。他在威尔顿庄园写下了它，并把它献给了他的妹妹彭布罗克伯爵夫人。那首诗中最著名的一句是：“有高尚思想陪伴的人永远不会孤独”，非常动人且鼓舞人心。西德尼可以随心所欲地写这类东西，因为每个人都认为这正是他的本色。我认为他，
for kind of Tudor-Cortier fanboys. I mean, he's the embodiment of that. He is the quintessence of Elizabethan nobility. And yet there is a sense of ambitions unfulfilled, isn't that? Because although he likes winning tournaments and he likes writing sonnets and all of these kinds of things and cutting a dash, his ambitions go much further. What he actually wants to do is to make his imprint on history and indeed on the map of Europe. because we started with that background, the sense of conflict on the continent. And that's a really, really important part of understanding what happens to Philip Sidney.
对于都铎王朝廷臣的粉丝来说，他是那种形象的化身。他是伊丽莎白时代贵族精神的精髓。然而，这其中有一种雄心未酬的感觉，不是吗？因为尽管他喜欢赢得锦标赛，喜欢写十四行诗，喜欢风度翩翩，但他的抱负远不止于此。他真正想要做的是在历史上，甚至在欧洲地图上留下自己的印记。因为我们从那个背景开始，即欧洲大陆上的冲突感。这对于理解菲利普·西德尼的遭遇来说，是非常非常重要的一部分。
Yes, he wants to go to a real war. He doesn't want to just kind of prance around in tournaments. And I think that this is partly he has a great devotion to the old medieval ideals of chivalry. They often feature in his poetry. But I think it also reflects something new. and that is the kind of the militant fusion of Protestantism and English patriotism, of which Sir Francis Drake has become, by this point, the absolute exemplar. And Sydney is about 15 years younger than Drake, so he was born in 1554,
是的，他想去参加真正的战争。他不想只是在锦标赛中炫耀。我认为这部分是因为他对中世纪的骑士精神有着极大的崇拜。这些精神经常出现在他的诗歌中。但我认为这也反映了一些新的东西，那就是新教与英国爱国主义的某种激进融合，弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士在这一点上已经成为了绝对的典范。西德尼比德雷克年轻约15岁，所以他出生于1554年，
and that means that he can't really remember a time when Elizabeth hadn't been on the throne and therefore when Protestant England had not been locked in a kind of desperate struggle. for survival. But the problem for Sydney, or the frustration, is that his ambition to fight for the Queen and Country and the cause of true religion has constantly been frustrated, because of course, although England is locked in a cold war, it isn't a war that offers much opportunity for a would-be knight-errant to win glory for himself. And this is because Elizabeth hates war. She's very cautious. He's very skeptical. She's very pragmatic. And she has no wish whatsoever to get locked into an open fight with Spain, which is the absolute, not just the European, but the global superpower.
这意味着他真的不记得伊丽莎白女王不在位的时候，也不记得新教英国没有陷入那种绝望的生存斗争的时候。但对西德尼来说，问题或挫折在于，他为女王、国家和真正宗教事业而战的雄心一直受挫，因为当然，尽管英国陷入了冷战，但这并不是一场能让一个想成为游侠骑士的人赢得荣耀的战争。这是因为伊丽莎白讨厌战争。她非常谨慎。她非常怀疑。她非常务实。她根本不想陷入与西班牙的公开冲突，因为西班牙不仅是欧洲，而且是全球的超级大国。
But I think there's an additional more personal reason why Sydney's ambition up until this point to win glory on the battlefield has been frustrated is because actually, although Sydney is cast as the ultimate courtier at the court of Elizabeth I, Elizabeth doesn't really trust him. Right. I think that she finds him maybe too well connected, kind of too independent-minded, too kind of aggressively, virally, friarily, Protestant. And it may be that she just thinks he's a little bit too much. He's a little bit over the top, which to a degree he is, I think. Well, he has behaved in not exactly insolent, but a very forward way, hasn't he?
但我认为，西德尼在此之前想要在战场上赢得荣耀的雄心受挫，还有一个更个人的原因，那就是实际上，尽管西德尼被塑造为伊丽莎白一世宫廷里的终极廷臣，但伊丽莎白并不真正信任他。没错。我想她可能觉得他的人脉太广，思想太独立，而且那种新教徒的姿态太激进、太狂热了。可能她只是觉得他有点过头了。他在某种程度上确实如此。嗯，他的行为不能说是无礼，但确实非常冒进，不是吗？
Because when she wanted to marry that bloke, the Duke of Anjou, we talked about him in the last episode. So he had bandy legs. She called him her frog. He was the brother, wasn't he, of the third? Is he the brother of the King of France? Have I got that right? Yeah, of Henry III.
因为当她想嫁给那个家伙，安茹公爵时，我们在上一集里谈到过他。他有罗圈腿。她叫他“青蛙”。他是亨利三世的兄弟，对吧？他是法国国王的兄弟吗？我没记错吧？是的，亨利三世的兄弟。
Yeah. And Philip Sidney had actually written her a letter and said, like, this is a very bad idea. I don't think you should do this, all of this kind of thing. I mean, that's great. That takes a lot of guts, but it might be seen as insubordinate. Well, I think it's definitely seen as insubordinate by Elizabeth. I mean, she is absolutely furious. And there's a sense in which his presence at that tournament in 1581 had been
是的。菲利普·西德尼实际上给她写了一封信，说：“这真是个坏主意。我不认为你应该这样做”，诸如此类。我的意思是，这很棒。这需要很大的勇气，但可能会被视为不服从。嗯，我认为伊丽莎白绝对认为这是不服从。我的意思是，她非常愤怒。在某种意义上，他在1581年那场锦标赛上的出现，
forced on Sydney by the Queen as a kind of humiliation because the French emissaries that he mentions in the in the sonnet, you know, from that sweet enemy France, had actually, these are emissaries who'd been sent by enjou. So in a sense, the fact that Sydney is having to entertain them with his knightly prowess, you know, this is Elizabeth rubbing his nose in the fact that she's going to marry enjou if she wants and there's nothing that he can do about it. And there's also have been some tennis bad behavior, hasn't it? Yes. Yeah.
是被女王强加给西德尼的一种羞辱，因为他在十四行诗中提到的那些法国使节，你知道，“来自那个甜蜜的敌人法国”，实际上是安茹派来的使节。所以从某种意义上说，西德尼不得不以他的骑士风采来招待他们，这是伊丽莎白在羞辱他，告诉他如果她想嫁给安茹，她就会嫁，而他对此无能为力。而且还有一些网球场上的不当行为，不是吗？是的。是的。
So talk us through this tennis business. So I think what this displays is the lack of a kind of Jimmy Carter figure. Yeah. At the court of Elizabeth I first. Because Jimmy Carter, of course, he would organize the timings on tennis courts. But there's clearly, there's no such figure at the court of Elizabeth because Sydney is playing tennis and the Earl of Oxford turns up and says that he's booked it. And therefore, Sydney has to get off. And there's a massive bust up.
那么给我们讲讲这个网球事件吧。我认为这显示了伊丽莎白一世宫廷里缺乏像吉米·卡特那样的人物。是的。因为吉米·卡特当然会安排网球场的时间。但伊丽莎白的宫廷里显然没有这样的人物，因为西德尼正在打网球，牛津伯爵出现了，说他已经预订了场地。因此，西德尼不得不离开。于是爆发了一场激烈的争吵。
Oxford ends up calling Sydney a puppy, which is tremendous insult. And Elizabeth had ended up personally intervening and scolding Sydney for forgetting the fact that he may be the nephew of the Earl of Leicester, but the Earl of Oxford is an Earl and massively outranks him both in age and status. And he should remember his place. And you can see the kind of the impact that this has on Sydney standing at court from the fact that, He is only knighted when he is 29, so in 1583. So when he is fighting that tournament in 1581, he's not even Sir Philip Sidney. So that's quite an insult, I think. So the question is, is Sydney going to overcome Elizabeth the first suspicion of him?
牛津伯爵最终称西德尼为“小狗”，这是一种巨大的侮辱。伊丽莎白最终亲自出面干预，并训斥了西德尼，因为他忘记了这样一个事实：尽管他可能是莱斯特伯爵的侄子，但牛津伯爵是一位伯爵，在年龄和地位上都远高于他。他应该记住自己的身份。你可以从他被封为爵士的时间看出这对西德尼在宫廷地位的影响，他直到29岁，也就是1583年才被封为爵士。所以当他在1581年参加那场锦标赛时，他甚至还不是菲利普·西德尼爵士。所以我认为这是一种相当大的侮辱。那么问题是，西德尼能克服伊丽莎白一世对他的怀疑吗？
Is he going to have a chance of a crack at the glory that he has alluded to him all his life, the prize? and big spoiler alert for our listeners. Yes, he is. He's going to get a chance of those things. Yeah, and it's because, as you said, at the start of this episode, by 1585, so four years on from that tournament, the drumbeat of war is indeed sounding.
他有机会获得他一生都在追求的荣耀吗，那个奖项？给我们的听众一个剧透警告。是的，他会有的。他会得到机会的。是的，正如你在本集开头所说，到1585年，也就是那场锦标赛四年后，战争的鼓声确实响起了。
And England is starting to be drawn against all Elizabeth's desperate attempts to avoid it into open conflict with Spain. It's no longer a Cold War. It is becoming English against Spain. on the field of battle. And this is taking place in the key theatre of the rivalry between Catholic and Protestant powers, which are the low countries. And we've been talking about this throughout this series. It is where a battle-hardened Spanish army under the command of the
英国开始被卷入与西班牙的公开冲突，尽管伊丽莎白竭尽全力避免。这不再是冷战了。这正在变成英国与西班牙在战场上的对抗。而这正发生在天主教和新教势力竞争的关键舞台——低地国家。我们在本系列中一直在讨论这个问题。在那里，一支由欧洲最伟大的将军指挥的久经沙场的西班牙军队，到1585年似乎即将粉碎荷兰的新教叛军。如果他们做到了，那么他们就获得了一个坚实的跳板，
greatest general in Europe seems by 1585 to be on the verge of crushing the Dutch Protestant rebels. And if they do that, then they are securing a solid launch pad. foreign invasion of England. And the great general there will have at his back this terrifying battle-hardened army. And this is a key moment, obviously, in the brewing conflict between England and Spain, but also just to kind of widen the camera angle a little bit. The events of 1585 and the years that follow are going to have consequences for the low countries that are with us still today, because the 17 provinces that constituted the Spanish Netherlands had formed a kind of single dynastic unit for most of the 16th century. And both sides
用于入侵英国。而那位伟大的将军身后将拥有这支可怕的、久经沙场的军队。这显然是英西冲突中一个关键时刻，但为了稍微拓宽一下视角，1585年及随后的事件对低地国家产生的影响至今仍伴随着我们，因为构成西班牙属尼德兰的17个省在16世纪的大部分时间里形成了一个单一的王朝单位。双方
in the Dutch revolt, so the Spanish and the rebels, they're fighting to maintain that unity. The events that we're going to be describing today will confirm that an irrevocable split has opened up between the northern provinces and the southern provinces of what had been the united low countries ruled by the Habsburg Kings. This is a split that gives us two modern-day countries, doesn't it? So talk us through the split and what that means for the map of Europe. Yes, so if you imagine the low countries, which today are the Netherlands and Belgium, they're kind of separated by these great rivers, these four great rivers,
在荷兰起义中，即西班牙人和叛军，都在为维持这种统一而战。我们今天将要描述的事件将证实，在曾经由哈布斯堡国王统治的统一低地国家的北部省份和南部省份之间，已经出现了一条不可逆转的裂痕。这是一条造就了两个现代国家的裂痕，不是吗？那么给我们讲讲这个分裂，以及这对欧洲地图意味着什么。是的，如果你想象一下低地国家，也就是今天的荷兰和比利时，它们被这些大河，这四条大河隔开，
which form a kind of natural barrier. This is effectively the boundary between the northern provinces and the southern provinces in the low countries. And the northern provinces will succeed in holding the Spanish at bay. And in due course, this will become what is known as the Dutch Republic. A great Protestant powerhouse in the 17th century, madly rich, effectively the inventor of modern capitalism, the civilization that will give us Rembrandt and Vermeer and so on. The South, meanwhile, is going to end up reconciled to Spanish rule. It will continue to be ruled by the Habsburgs, ultimately right the way up until the age of the French Revolution.
它们形成了一种天然的屏障。这实际上是低地国家北部省份和南部省份之间的边界。北部省份将成功地将西班牙人拒之门外。最终，这将成为所谓的荷兰共和国。17世纪的一个伟大的新教强国，极其富有，实际上是现代资本主义的发明者，孕育了伦勃朗和维米尔等人的文明。与此同时，南部最终将与西班牙的统治和解。它将继续由哈布斯堡家族统治，一直持续到法国大革命时代。
It will re-embrace Catholicism and it will become in the wake of the Napoleonic Wars, so two and a half centuries after the period that we're talking about now, it will become Belgium. So it's Rembrandt versus Rubens, I guess, is one way of thinking about it. Or Amsterdam versus Antwerp. Yeah, so it's a pivotal moment, not just in the, you know, the theme of this series, the Cold War between England and Spain, but for the future. geopolitics of Europe. And there is a sense of this in the 1580s, I think, a sense that the stakes are massively cosmically high, you know, that God himself is gazing down at this tremendous conflict. And it is this conflict, as we will see, that is a huge part of what ends up making Philip Sidney very, very famous indeed.
它将重新拥抱天主教，并在拿破仑战争之后，也就是在我们现在讨论的时期两个半世纪后，它将成为比利时。所以我想这可以看作是伦勃朗与鲁本斯的对决。或者阿姆斯特丹与安特卫普的对决。是的，这是一个关键时刻，不仅是在本系列的主题——英西冷战中，而且对欧洲未来的地缘政治也是如此。我认为在1580年代有一种感觉，一种赌注极其巨大、极其神圣的感觉，你知道，上帝本人正在注视着这场巨大的冲突。正如我们将要看到的，正是这场冲突，在很大程度上成就了菲利普·西德尼的巨大名声。
Europe. So Philip Sidney is the star of today's episode and let's take a closer look at him. So in 1584 he turns 30. So he's born in 1554. But in those first 30 years, he has met almost every major character that we've had so far in this series. He's the Selig of 16th century Europe. Right. And let's start actually with his name. So his name is very unusual, isn't it? It's not an English name. Not really. No. There aren't many Phillips in English history before him. They were called Henry and Robert. Right.
欧洲。所以菲利普·西德尼是今天这一集的主角，让我们仔细看看他。1584年他30岁了。他出生于1554年。但在那前30年里，他几乎见过了我们本系列到目前为止提到的所有主要人物。他是16世纪欧洲的“塞利格”（Selig）。没错。让我们从他的名字开始。他的名字非常不寻常，不是吗？这不是一个英国名字。确实不是。在他之前，英国历史上没有多少叫菲利普的。他们通常叫亨利和罗伯特。没错。
As you say in your notes, it's like an American politician, a fervently anti-communist, American politician from, I don't know, born in Iowa or something being called Fidel. Or Nikita. Right, exactly. Vladimir. Yeah. So is this a tribute to Philip of Spain, his name?
正如你在笔记中所说，这就像一个美国政客，一个狂热的反共美国政客，我不知道，出生在爱荷华州什么的，却被叫作“菲德尔”。或者“尼基塔”。没错，正是这样。弗拉基米尔。是的。那么这个名字是为了向西班牙的菲利普致敬吗？
Yes, it is. So Philip Sidney is born in 1554 before Elizabeth has come to the throne. It's when her sister, the Catholic Mary Tudor, is still queen. And people who heard our opening episode may remember, Mary Tudor had married the future Philip the second of Spain. So Philip the second of Spain had briefly been king of England. And so he'd come to England for the nuptials and to spend time with his new bride. And he didn't speak English. So he's quite lonely. But Philip Sidney's father had, he had spoken Spanish. And so Philip of Spain and Philip Sidney's father become great pals.
是的，确实如此。菲利普·西德尼出生于1554年，在伊丽莎白即位之前。那时她的姐姐，天主教徒玛丽·都铎还是女王。听过我们第一集的人可能还记得，玛丽·都铎嫁给了未来的西班牙菲利普二世。所以西班牙菲利普二世曾短暂地担任过英国国王。他来到英国参加婚礼，并与他的新婚妻子共度时光。他不会说英语。所以他很孤独。但菲利普·西德尼的父亲会说西班牙语。于是西班牙菲利普和菲利普·西德尼的父亲成了好朋友。
And so Philip Sidney's father gets Philip the second as he will become to stand as his newborn son's godfather. And so that's why Philip is named after Philip of Spain. So even when he's a little baby, Philip Sidney is meeting very famous people. And Philip the second would have to be the first celebrity that he's met. But absolutely not the last. So just to run through all the celebrities and famous names that Philip Sidney meets over the course of his brief life. So in 1572, by which point Sydney is 17, he goes on a kind of extended gap year to Paris where he stays with Francis Walsingham, who at the time is the English ambassador to the court of France.
所以菲利普·西德尼的父亲请未来的菲利普二世担任他刚出生儿子的教父。这就是为什么菲利普是以西班牙菲利普的名字命名的。所以即使在他还是个婴儿的时候，菲利普·西德尼就已经在见非常有名的人了。而菲利普二世一定是他见过的第一个名人。但这绝对不是最后一个。让我们快速浏览一下菲利普·西德尼在他短暂的一生中见过的所有名人和著名名字。1572年，当时西德尼17岁，他去巴黎进行了一次延长的间隔年旅行，在那里他住在当时担任英国驻法国大使的弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆家中。
And he is there for the St. Baltholomew's Day massacre. And he witnesses the slaughter. And of course, this has an enormous impact on him. It confirms him in the kind of the militant quality of his Protestantism and his closeness to Walsingham. And actually in due course in 1583, Sydney will become Walsingham's son-in-law. So he is very much part of that kind of cold warrior Puritan strain within the Elizabethan establishment. Right. From Paris, Sydney then goes on a European tour. And in the course of this tour, he meets with Henry III, the new king of France. So played by Andrew Scott, I think we agreed. And Henry the third at the time, he's returning from
他亲历了圣巴托罗缪大屠杀。他目睹了那场杀戮。当然，这对他的影响巨大。这坚定了他新教信仰的激进性质，以及他与沃尔辛厄姆的亲密关系。实际上，在1583年，西德尼成为了沃尔辛厄姆的女婿。所以他确实是伊丽莎白体制内那种冷战战士清教徒派系的一部分。没错。从巴黎出发，西德尼随后进行了欧洲巡回旅行。在这次旅行中，他见到了法国新国王亨利三世。我想我们一致认为由安德鲁·斯科特扮演。当时的亨利三世正从
Poland, where he'd been the king. But becoming king of France is obviously an upgrade. And Sydney hangs out with Henry III in Venice. And Henry makes him a baron of France. So that's a kind of, again, a measure of just how charismatic and appealing Sydney is. He then goes to the last countries, where he meets with William of Orange, The Silent, the great hero of the Dutch revolt, who we talked about in our episode on the Dutch National Anthem. And just to remind people who may not have heard that episode, William the Silent had at one point been a very loyal servant of the Habsburgs of Philip II personally, but has since become his most implacable opponent. And he is the military, the moral, the symbolic leader of the Dutch
波兰返回，他在那里曾是国王。但成为法国国王显然是一种升级。西德尼在威尼斯与亨利三世混在一起。亨利封他为法国男爵。所以这再次衡量了西德尼是多么有魅力和吸引力。他随后去了低地国家，在那里他见到了“沉默者”威廉·奥兰治，即我们在关于荷兰国歌的那一集中谈到的荷兰起义的伟大英雄。为了提醒那些可能没听过那一集的人，威廉·沉默者曾一度是哈布斯堡家族和菲利普二世个人的忠实仆人，但后来成为了他最不可调和的对手。他是荷兰
revolt and William loves Sydney. And Alan Stewart in his biography of Philip Sidney, a double life, suggests that maybe William wanted Sydney to be his son-in-law. And I think Sydney was quite keen on that. But Elizabeth predictably forbade it, you know, she didn't want Sydney shacking up with maybe the future leader of an independent Dutch kingdom. Yeah, she doesn't want his star to shine too brightly, does she? No, no.
起义的军事、道德和象征性领袖。威廉很喜欢西德尼。艾伦·斯图尔特在菲利普·西德尼的传记《双重生活》中暗示，也许威廉想让西德尼成为他的女婿。我想西德尼对此也相当热衷。但伊丽莎白不出所料地禁止了它，你知道，她不想让西德尼与可能是一个独立荷兰王国的未来领袖联姻。是的，她不想让他太出风头，对吧？不，不。
But then he goes off to Prague where he meets Rudolf, the second, the great enthusiast for the occult. And also in Prague, he meets with Edmund Campion, the Jesuit, who we talked about in episode two of this series, who comes to England and ends up being kind of very brutally martyred. On his return from Prague, he is debriefed in person by William Cecil, Lord Burley, effectively Elizabeth's prime minister. He runs short of money. You know, he's a young gentleman at court. That's what young gentlemen at court do. They're always short cash. And so he borrows money from Sir Christopher Hatton, the guy who'd funded Francis Drake's circumnavigation around the world. He is the patron of one of the great Elizabethan poets,
但他随后去了布拉格，在那里他见到了鲁道夫二世，那位伟大的神秘学爱好者。在布拉格，他还见到了我们在本系列第二集中谈到的耶稣会士埃德蒙·坎皮恩，他后来回到英国并被极其残忍地处决。从布拉格回来后，他亲自向威廉·塞西尔（伯利勋爵），即伊丽莎白的实际首相进行了汇报。他缺钱了。你知道，他是宫廷里的年轻绅士。年轻绅士在宫廷里就是这样。他们总是缺钱。于是他向克里斯托弗·哈顿爵士借钱，就是那个资助了弗朗西斯·德雷克环球航行的人。他是伊丽莎白时代伟大的诗人之一，
Edmund Spencer, who dedicates a poem to him, hails him as the precedent of all chivalry. So Sydney is very much part of the kind of the literary circles of this Elizabethan golden age. We talked about Giadano Bruno, the Neapolitan friar turned kind of free-thinking skeptic who will end up being burnt in Rome and who may have been a spy at the French embassy in London. Anyway, Sydney met up with him, thought he was great, went to Oxford with Bruno, where Bruno gave a lecture on Copernicus on the idea that the earth moves around the sun. and he has also met John D, the great necromancer again. We did an episode on him and he had accompanied Elizabeth on a barge down the Thames to Mortlake where Dee had his house. So basically anything famous that happens in the 1570s, the 1580s, Sydney pops up. He's there.
埃德蒙·斯宾塞的赞助人，斯宾塞把一首诗献给他，称他为所有骑士精神的典范。所以西德尼确实是伊丽莎白黄金时代文学圈的一部分。我们谈到了焦尔达诺·布鲁诺，那位那不勒斯的修士变成了自由思想的怀疑论者，他最终在罗马被烧死，并且可能曾是伦敦法国大使馆的间谍。总之，西德尼见过他，觉得他很棒，还和布鲁诺一起去了牛津，在那里布鲁诺发表了一场关于哥白尼的演讲，关于地球绕太阳转的观点。他还见过伟大的死灵法师约翰·迪。我们又做了一集关于他的节目，他曾陪同伊丽莎白乘驳船沿泰晤士河前往迪的住所莫特莱克。所以基本上，1570年代、1580年代发生的任何著名事件，西德尼都会出现。他在那里。
He is the man on the scene. And then of course, there is the greatest celebrity of the age, perhaps the most famous man in all of Europe, Sydney's great mates with Sir Francis Drake. Right. So what's Sir Francis Drake? What's he been up to since we last saw him? So he got knighted. He was knighted on the ship, on the golden hind.
他是现场的人。当然，还有那个时代最伟大的名人，也许是整个欧洲最著名的人，西德尼是弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士的好朋友。没错。那么弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士呢？自从我们上次见到他以来，他一直在做什么？他被封为爵士了。他在船上，在“金鹿号”上被封为爵士。
The French ambassador very much in attendance, a very prominent figure. It was a sort of sign, wasn't it, to the Spanish, a sort of a little gesture of England's rapprochement. A V sign, one might almost say. Exactly. So what's he been up to? He hasn't been back being a sea dog, has he? He's been on land.
法国大使非常在场，是一个非常显眼的人物。这是一种信号，不是吗？对西班牙人的一种姿态，一种英国和解的小动作。甚至可以说是一个V字手势。正是如此。那么他一直在做什么？他没有回去做海狗，对吧？他在陆地上。
No, he's been having a very quiet time of it. So he's been investing in property. He's bought four houses, all very fancy. Okay. He's been serving as an MP. He's been elected mayor of Plymouth. And he's been legislating to regulate the Pilchard trade, which is obviously very important. But it's not really Drake's vibe regulating the pilchard trade.
不，他过得很安静。他在投资房地产。他买了四栋房子，都非常豪华。好的。他一直在担任议员。他当选为普利茅斯市长。他一直在立法监管沙丁鱼贸易，这显然非常重要。但监管沙丁鱼贸易并不是德雷克的风格。
Right. And I think this is why he gets on so well with. Sydney because both of them are basically bored and itching for a decent war. They want to have a crack at the dawn. And Drake is a bit like Churchill in the 1930s. You know, he is sure that a great life or death struggle is approaching for England. And again, like Churchill in the 1930s, he is obsessed with the need for England to beef up her defences. And this is how he comes into contact with Sydney because Sydney since 1583 has been the master of ordinance, which means that he is charged with preparing England against attack.
没错。我想这就是为什么他和西德尼相处得这么好。因为他们基本上都很无聊，渴望一场像样的战争。他们想大干一场。德雷克有点像1930年代的丘吉尔。你知道，他确信一场伟大的生死斗争即将来临。同样，像1930年代的丘吉尔一样，他痴迷于英国需要加强防御的必要性。这就是他与西德尼接触的方式，因为西德尼自1583年以来一直担任军械总管，这意味着他负责准备英国以应对攻击。
And so both men, I think, are very much singing from the same hymn sheet. I mean, actually probably literally because their form of kind of fiery Protestantism is very similar. And by 1585, definitely, it's becoming clear that both Drake and Sydney are right to be warning that war with Spain is approaching. think by this point, even Elizabeth very reluctantly is having to acknowledge that Philip the second in Spain is indeed preparing for war. Well, now, why is that? Because surely he would be a, anxious about the French, and B, he's too busy fighting the Dutch, or is he? Well, the French
所以我想，两人在很大程度上是志同道合的。我的意思是，实际上可能字面上也是如此，因为他们那种激进的新教信仰非常相似。到1585年，毫无疑问，德雷克和西德尼都在警告说与西班牙的战争即将来临，这一点正变得越来越清楚。我想到了这一点，即使是伊丽莎白也非常不情愿地不得不承认，西班牙的菲利普二世确实在准备战争。嗯，现在，为什么呢？因为他肯定会，A，担心法国人，B，他太忙于与荷兰人作战了，还是说他不是？嗯，法国人
basically have been removed as a factor in his calculations because people who listened to our previous episode may remember there are these three Henri, three Henrys, doing this delicate minuet around each other. But by 1585, all three men are starting to go to war with each other. So you've got the Huguenots under Henry of Navarre, who I think was going to be played by Pedro Pascal in our film of this story. You've got the Catholic League under Henry of Gies. Mads-Michelson. Mads-Lickleson, he's got a great scar across his face, passionate Catholic. And you've got the royalists who are loyal to the king, Henry III, so Andrew Scott, and all these three factions are turning on each other. And the resulting war is going to rage for four years.
基本上已经被排除在他的计算因素之外了，因为听过我们上一集的人可能还记得，有这三个亨利，三个亨利，在彼此周围跳着精致的小步舞。但到1585年，这三个人都开始互相开战了。所以你有亨利·纳瓦拉领导的胡格诺派，我想在我们的电影中他将由佩德罗·帕斯卡扮演。你有亨利·吉斯领导的天主教联盟。麦斯·米科尔森。麦斯·米科尔森，他脸上有一道巨大的伤疤，充满激情的天主教徒。还有忠于国王亨利三世的保皇党，也就是安德鲁·斯科特，这三个派系都在互相攻击。由此产生的战争将持续四年。
And it will come to be known inevitably as the war of the three Henrys. And for as long as it's raging, France effectively is paralyzed. And for as long as France is paralyzed, Philip of Spain has a free hand. He doesn't need to worry about what the French will do. So that's the French. What's about, or what's going on in the low countries? Because that really has been the cockpit of Europe's wars of religion for the last few years. Well, what's happened there is that the most dynamic and significant leader of the Dutch rebels has been eliminated, William of Orange, William the Silent. And he had been assassinated the previous summer on the 10th of July, 1584. He'd been shot on a staircase in his kind of very modest quarters in Delft.
它将不可避免地被称为“三亨利之战”。只要它还在进行，法国实际上就瘫痪了。只要法国瘫痪，西班牙菲利普就有自由行动的空间。他不需要担心法国人会做什么。所以那是法国。那么低地国家发生了什么？因为那确实是过去几年欧洲宗教战争的中心。嗯，那里发生的事情是，荷兰叛军中最具活力和重要性的领袖被消灭了，威廉·奥兰治，威廉·沉默者。他于前一年夏天，1584年7月10日被暗杀。他在代尔夫特他那相当简朴的住所的楼梯上被枪杀。
William of Orange had once been one of the richest men in Europe, but he has spent all his money on keeping the Dutch revolt afloat. So he's now basically bankrupt. And the assassin had been inspired to murder the Prince of Orange by two factors. Firstly, his own devout Catholicism, but secondly, by a bounty that Philip had placed on William's head in 1580. And as William dies, his last thoughts are of his fellow rebels. in Holland and the northern provinces. And he cries out, my God, have mercy on me and on my poor people. But has God been listening to this prayer? In the wake of Williams' assassination, it seems not. Because in the months that follow Williams' assassination, the revel provinces in the low countries are brought almost to the point of collapse. And in part, I think this is due to the loss of Williams' leadership, but it is also due to the brilliance of the captain they were facing on the battlefield. Remember, we said, the Spanish in the low countries are led by the greatest general of the age.
威廉·奥兰治曾经是欧洲最富有的人之一，但他把所有的钱都花在了维持荷兰起义上。所以他现在基本上破产了。刺客受到两个因素的启发去谋杀奥兰治亲王。首先，他自己虔诚的天主教信仰，其次，菲利普在1580年为威廉的人头悬赏。当威廉去世时，他最后的念头是他的叛军同伴。在荷兰和北部省份。他大喊：“上帝啊，怜悯我和我可怜的人民。”但上帝听到了这个祈祷吗？在威廉被暗杀后，似乎没有。因为在威廉被暗杀后的几个月里，低地国家的叛乱省份几乎到了崩溃的边缘。在某种程度上，我认为这是由于威廉领导力的丧失，但也是由于他们在战场上所面对的指挥官的才华。记住，我们说过，低地国家的西班牙人由这个时代最伟大的将军指挥。
And this is a guy called Alexander Farnese, the Prince of Palmer, and he is a completely terrifying adversary. So he's an Italian, isn't he, or Italian-born? He's the son of the Duke of Palmer. but the key thing is that his mother who'd been born in Flanders and she has I mean we love to do these
这是一个叫亚历山大·法尔内塞的人，帕尔马亲王，他是一个完全可怕的对手。所以他是个意大利人，对吧？或者意大利出生的？他是帕尔马公爵的儿子。但关键是他的母亲，她出生在佛兰德斯，她有——我的意思是，我们喜欢做这些
when we're doing the First World War we like to draw attention to the moustaches of the leading generals and I mean we're not going to be talking about Alexander Farnese the Prince of Palmer's moustache
当我们谈论第一次世界大战时，我们喜欢关注主要将军的胡子，我的意思是，我们不会谈论亚历山大·法尔内塞，帕尔马亲王的胡子
I mean he has a good moustache he has a good moustache but it's not as striking as his mother's moustache is that fair or is that ungalant it's a bit ungallant but I think fair she is well known for her moustache She is Philip the second's half-sister, and Philip had appointed her to serve as the governor of the low countries in the 1560s. And it's her period running the low countries that had resulted in the revolt breaking out.
我的意思是，他有一撇好胡子，他有一撇好胡子，但没有他母亲的胡子那么引人注目，这公平吗，还是说这不礼貌？这有点不礼貌，但我认为很公平，她以她的胡子而闻名。她是菲利普二世同父异母的妹妹，菲利普曾任命她在1560年代担任低地国家的总督。正是她管理低地国家的时期导致了起义的爆发。
So she doesn't have a great track record. But Palmer is, as we've said, an incredibly formidable man. And he's been serving as both the Governor General of the Netherlands and the Captain General of the Army of Flanders since, Since 1578, so he combines both the civil and the military responsibilities in his single person. And he's been doing an amazing job. So just to give the summary of Jeffrey Parker, the great historian of the Dutch revolt and Spain more generally in the 16th century, Parma was able and resourceful, rich and cultivated, subtle and shrewd. He excelled in both diplomacy and war. And the measure of his achievement is that back in 1578, when he'd first been appointed, the Spanish Corps,
所以她的记录并不好。但帕尔马正如我们所说，是一个极其强大的人。自1578年以来，他一直担任尼德兰总督和佛兰德斯军队的队长，所以他集民事和军事职责于一身。他做得非常出色。所以，引用16世纪荷兰起义和西班牙历史学家杰弗里·帕克的总结，帕尔马能干且足智多谋，富有且有教养，微妙且精明。他擅长外交和战争。他成就的衡量标准是，早在1578年他刚被任命时，西班牙军队，
in the low countries had seemed on the verge of complete collapse. But by 1584, when William the silent is assassinated, he has pulled things back dramatically from the brink. And he's done that by kind of employing a mix of the carrot and the stick. So he's essentially brought the southern reaches of the low countries, the portion that is in the long run going to become Belgium. He's brought them back under Spanish control. Most of the south, which has had been in a state of rebellion, has submitted to Palmer's armies. Many of their key cities have surrendered, and others, among them Brussels, so the capital of the EU now, and Ghent, a very favourite holiday destination for people going on long weekends from Britain. Incredibly beautiful
在低地国家似乎处于彻底崩溃的边缘。但到1584年威廉·沉默者被暗杀时，他已经戏剧性地将局势从崩溃边缘拉了回来。他通过采取胡萝卜加大棒的策略做到了这一点。所以他基本上把低地国家的南部地区，也就是长期来看将成为比利时的那部分，带回了西班牙的控制之下。大部分曾经处于叛乱状态的南部地区已经向帕尔马的军队投降。他们的许多关键城市已经投降，而其他的，包括布鲁塞尔——现在欧盟的首都——和根特，一个非常受英国人周末度假欢迎的目的地。极其美丽的
city. Both of these are under siege and are clearly on the verge of surrender. And the murder of William the Silent in 1584, essentially everything starts collapsing once the news of his death reaches the rebels in the South. So in September, just two months after William had been assassinated, Ghent finally falls. And I think when you go to Ghent today, its vibe is so Catholic that it's really odd to think that there was a time when it was the cockpit of an incredibly radical Protestant regime, which had seized control there in. 1577, it had instituted a kind of full-blown militant republic, it had broken images, it had persecuted Catholics, it had smashed up rude screens, all that kind of stuff. They have to surrender.
城市。这两个城市都处于围困之中，显然处于投降的边缘。而1584年威廉·沉默者的谋杀，基本上当他死亡的消息传到南部的叛军耳中时，一切都开始崩溃了。所以9月，就在威廉被暗杀两个月后，根特终于陷落了。我想当你今天去根特时，它的氛围是如此天主教，以至于很难想象曾经有一段时间它是极其激进的新教政权的中心，该政权于1577年夺取了控制权。它建立了一种全面的激进共和国，它打破了偶像，它迫害天主教徒，它砸碎了圣坛屏风，所有这些东西。他们不得不投降。
Palmer, as is his custom, offers very merciful terms. So he's applied the stick, now he's dangling the carrot. But it does mean that Catholicism is reinstated as the official religion of the city, and most of the Protestants in Ghent are not prepared to put up with that. Palmer has said, If you don't like this, you know, I'm not going to slaughter you. I'm not going to persecute you. You can just go. You can just leave the city. And probably about 15,000 Protestants, so that's maybe a third of the population, end up leaving Ghent and heading to Holland.
帕尔马，按照他的习惯，提供了非常仁慈的条件。所以他用了大棒，现在他悬挂着胡萝卜。但这确实意味着天主教被恢复为城市的官方宗教，而根特的大多数新教徒并不准备忍受这一点。帕尔马说：“如果你不喜欢这样，你知道，我不会屠杀你。我不会迫害你。你可以走。你可以离开这座城市。”可能大约有15000名新教徒，也就是人口的三分之一，最终离开了根特，前往荷兰。
And Holland is the overwhelming Protestant state in the northern Netherlands that by now is the beating heart of the revolt. So remember, it is screened from the south by those great rivers. So it is more readily defensible against the Spanish than the kind of the southern swatheaval. the sweep that's going to become Belgium. If we fast forward to the summer of 1585, I mean, you mentioned the rivers, but things are looking pretty bleak for the Protestant rebels in the north, aren't they? Because Brussels has finally fallen, that becomes the capital of Belgium in the long run. And the focus has moved to, so it's not quite midway between Brussels and Amsterdam, but
而荷兰是北部尼德兰压倒性的新教国家，到目前为止，它是起义跳动的心脏。所以记住，它被那些大河与南部隔开。所以它比将成为比利时的南部地区更容易防御西班牙人。如果我们快进到1585年夏天，我的意思是，你提到了河流，但北部新教叛军的情况看起来相当惨淡，不是吗？因为布鲁塞尔终于陷落了，从长远来看，那成为了比利时的首都。而焦点已经转移到，所以它并不完全在布鲁塞尔和阿姆斯特丹之间，但
it's kind of, let's say, a quarter of the way, and that is Antwerp. So Antwerp, it's the biggest city in the low countries in this period. It is by far the richest. It is the city that has been bankrolling the rebellion. I mean, crucially, it controls this estuary, which is the estuary of the Scheldt, which kind of leads out towards the English Channel and to the North Sea. So the Schelt is the kind of, it's the absolutely vital connection. It's a key artery, really, yeah.
它大约是四分之一的路程，那就是安特卫普。所以安特卫普，它是这一时期低地国家最大的城市。它是迄今为止最富有的。它是为叛乱提供资金的城市。我的意思是，至关重要的是，它控制着这个河口，也就是斯海尔德河的河口，它通向英吉利海峡和北海。所以斯海尔德河是那种，它是绝对重要的连接。它确实是一条关键的动脉，是的。
Yeah, between the rich, Flemish cloth town. So that is Ghent and Bruges and these incredibly handsome places that people go to on city breaks today, between them and the sea and trade with England and so on and so forth. And people had thought, hadn't they, that Antwerp was impregnable because it's got these massive fortifications. Yeah. But this bloke Palmer, he likes a challenge. He likes to crack a hard nut, yeah. And he knows that Antwerp is the greatest price of all, because as you said, it's probably the richest city, certainly in Europe.
是的，在富裕的佛兰德斯纺织城镇之间。也就是根特和布鲁日，这些今天人们去城市度假时会造访的极其漂亮的城市，在它们与大海之间，以及与英国的贸易等等。人们曾以为安特卫普是坚不可摧的，对吧？因为它有这些巨大的防御工事。是的。但这个叫帕尔马的家伙，他喜欢挑战。他喜欢啃硬骨头，是的。而且他知道安特卫普是最大的奖赏，因为正如你所说，它可能是最富有的城市，至少在欧洲是这样。
I mean, maybe in the world. and it is the key Protestant stronghold. This is where Protestantism is strongest. And if he can take Antwerp, then he's probably thinking that is the end of the revolt. So he had embarked on the siege of Antwerp in June 1584, and he constructed an immense network of forts to cut off Antwerp's access to the interior of the southern low countries. But the key requirement is to stop supplies and men.
我的意思是，也许在世界上也是。它是新教的关键堡垒。这是新教势力最强的地方。如果他能拿下安特卫普，那么他可能认为起义就结束了。所以他在1584年6月开始了对安特卫普的围攻，并建造了一个巨大的堡垒网络，切断了安特卫普与低地国家南部内陆的联系。但关键的要求是切断补给和人员。
from the rebel held north reaching the city down the shelf, this kind of great estuary, which leads out into the North Sea. And Palmer achieves this by building a massive pontoon bridge, which his admirers are very proud of saying was twice the length of the bridge built by Julius Caesar over the Rhine. So it's almost half a mile in length. And the rebels are so desperate to destroy it that they send in fire ships, hellburners, they're called loaded with explosives to blow it up. And actually one of these fire ships does blow up.
从叛军控制的北方通过斯海尔德河到达这座城市，这条通往北海的巨大河口。帕尔马通过建造一座巨大的浮桥实现了这一点，他的崇拜者们非常自豪地说，这座桥的长度是尤利乌斯·凯撒在莱茵河上建造的桥的两倍。所以它有近半英里长。叛军非常绝望，想要摧毁它，于是他们派出了火船，被称为“地狱燃烧者”，装满了炸药去炸毁它。实际上，其中一艘火船确实爆炸了。
and it incinerates an entire section of the bridge, killing 800 Spanish soldiers. But Palmer is able to have it repaired before the Dutch rebels can come down and force their way through the gap that they've opened up. And so in late May the rebels try again, but this time their fleet makes a complete hash of things. The tide turns and sweeps them back towards their own lines, which is not a thing you want to see load of fire ships loaded with explosives coming towards you on a tide. And again, Palmer is able to repair.
它烧毁了整段桥梁，炸死了800名西班牙士兵。但帕尔马在荷兰叛军能够冲下来并强行穿过他们打开的缺口之前就将其修复了。所以在5月下旬，叛军再次尝试，但这一次他们的舰队把事情搞得一团糟。潮水转向并将他们冲回了自己的防线，这可不是你想看到的，一堆装满炸药的火船随着潮水向你冲来。帕尔马再次成功修复了。
the attack and to maintain the integrity of the pontoon bridge across the Scheldt. And this means that Antwerp is now completely invested and so starvation starts to grip the city and the rebels grow increasingly desperate. And they are looking around for allies. They need overseas support, but where are they going to get this support from? So in the previous episode, we talked about how the rebels had tried to get French backing in the form of enjou, the Duke who had been hoping to marry Elizabeth. But he had hashed things up. His mercenaries had run amok in Antwerp. He'd left in disgrace, and now he's dead. And so the rebels have tried to get his brother, Henry III of France, to take over the sovereignty of the low countries and come in against Spain. But as we've said,
这次袭击并保持了横跨斯海尔德河的浮桥的完整性。这意味着安特卫普现在被完全包围了，饥饿开始笼罩这座城市，叛军变得越来越绝望。他们正在寻找盟友。他们需要海外支持，但他们能从哪里获得这种支持呢？所以在上一集中，我们谈到了叛军是如何试图获得法国的支持，即安茹公爵，他曾希望娶伊丽莎白。但他把事情搞砸了。他的雇佣兵在安特卫普横行霸道。他蒙羞离开了，现在他死了。所以叛军试图让他的兄弟，法国的亨利三世，接管低地国家的主权并对抗西班牙。但正如我们所说，
Henry III is the king of a country that is now collapsing into civil war. So he doesn't have time to intervene in foreign squabbles. And this really leaves the rebels with just the one port of call. And this, of course, is a queen who is, as we've said, instinctively cautious, hate spending money on wars, hates wars full stop, very much disapproves of revolts against anointed monarchs. And this, of course, is Elizabeth of England. And so unsurprisingly, when the Dutch rebels go to London and offer her sovereignty over the low countries, she turns them down. However, she and her government do appreciate that they can't really just leave the rebels to the fate. It is existential for England as well as for the Dutch. And in particular, the impending fall of Antwerp is a nightmare
亨利三世是一个正陷入内战的国家国王。所以他没有时间干预外国的纷争。这真的让叛军只有一个求助对象。当然，这就是那位女王，正如我们所说，她天生谨慎，讨厌在战争上花钱，讨厌战争，非常不赞成反抗受膏的君主。当然，这就是英国的伊丽莎白。所以不出所料，当荷兰叛军去伦敦并向她提供低地国家的主权时，她拒绝了他们。然而，她和她的政府确实意识到，他们不能真的就这样任由叛军自生自灭。这对英国和荷兰人来说都是生死攸关的。特别是，安特卫普即将陷落是一个噩梦。
for English strategists. First of all, it risks. It risks. the collapse of the entire Dutch revolt. And if the Dutch revolt collapses, then as we've said, that means that Palmer and his terrifying army will be free to cross the sea and land in England. More broadly, it's a nightmare for the entire cause of Protestantism in Europe. And for Leicester, for Walsingham, for Sydney, definitely, this is probably the major consideration. You know, this is the future of what God wants for Christendom is at stake as they see it. And what about the economics of it? Because you mentioned how wealthy the Flemish Cloth towns are,
对于英国战略家来说。首先，它有风险。它有风险。整个荷兰起义的崩溃。如果荷兰起义崩溃，那么正如我们所说，这意味着帕尔马和他那支可怕的军队将可以自由地跨海并在英国登陆。更广泛地说，这对欧洲整个新教事业来说是一个噩梦。对于莱斯特、沃尔辛厄姆、悉尼来说，这绝对是主要的考虑因素。你知道，这是上帝对基督教未来的期望，在他们看来，这正处于危险之中。那么经济方面呢？因为你提到了佛兰德斯纺织城镇是多么富有，
how important that trade link is between the low countries and England in particular. I mean, surely if Antwerp was lost, if the low countries were lost, wouldn't that be disastrous for England's economy? Yeah, a complete disaster. I mean, there have been blockades going on and off throughout this period. But the thought of losing Antwerp, kind of Straits of Hummus, cubed basically for the English. I mean, it's a massive, massive disaster.
低地国家与英国之间的贸易联系有多重要。我的意思是，如果安特卫普丢失了，如果低地国家丢失了，这对英国经济来说难道不是灾难性的吗？是的，一场彻底的灾难。我的意思是，在这段时期内，封锁时断时续。但失去安特卫普的想法，对英国人来说基本上就是立方倍的霍尔木兹海峡。我的意思是，这是一场巨大的、巨大的灾难。
They cannot, basically, they cannot afford to have Antwerp under the control of a hostile power. And it is clear to them by now that Philip II is indeed an overtly hostile power who is looking to throttle the entire English economy because back in May 1585, he'd imposed an embargo on English vessels landing in Spanish and Portuguese ports. And this is a patent act of economic warfare. And so the prospect that he might end up in a position to impose a similar embargo on all the ports in the low countries, I mean, that is a complete nightmare. And it's a kind of nightmare that Elizabeth, who is always counting the pennies, that she can actually understand.
他们基本上无法承受让安特卫普处于敌对势力的控制之下。到目前为止，对他们来说很清楚，腓力二世确实是一个公开的敌对势力，他正试图扼杀整个英国经济，因为早在1585年5月，他就对在西班牙和葡萄牙港口停靠的英国船只实施了禁运。这是一种明显的经济战行为。因此，他最终可能处于能够对低地国家的所有港口实施类似禁运的地位，我的意思是，那是一个彻底的噩梦。这是一种伊丽莎白——那个总是精打细算的人——实际上能够理解的噩梦。
You know, she's less interested in glory than she is in making money. And this is enough to make her think, well, probably we should do something about this. And so by early August 1585, it's clear that Antwerp isn't going to hold out much longer. You know, they're thinking in terms of weeks, maybe days before the Spanish enter the city. And that means that Elizabeth, who given the choice, will always delay and prevaricate. It means that she has to arrive at a decision about what to do. And of course, much is going to depend on that decision, the course of the Dutch revolt, the prospects of open war between England and Spain
你知道，她对荣耀的兴趣不如对赚钱的兴趣大。这足以让她认为，好吧，我们也许应该对此做点什么。因此，到1585年8月初，很明显安特卫普撑不了多久了。你知道，他们认为西班牙人进入这座城市还需要几周，甚至几天。这意味着伊丽莎白，如果可以选择，她总是会拖延和推诿。这意味着她必须就该做什么做出决定。当然，很多事情将取决于那个决定，荷兰起义的进程，英国和西班牙之间公开战争的前景，
and the future of Sir Philip Sydney. Oh, that's exciting. Come back after the break to find out what happens next. This episode is brought to you by Amazon. Tom throughout history, change has often been driven by businesses and institutions that end up having a massive impact on society as a whole. And there's probably no better example than the Ford Motor Company. Henry Ford and his managers revolutionised production through their pioneering assembly lines.
以及菲利普·悉尼爵士的未来。哦，那太令人兴奋了。休息后回来看看接下来会发生什么。本集由亚马逊赞助。汤姆，纵观历史，变革往往是由最终对整个社会产生巨大影响的企业和机构推动的。可能没有比福特汽车公司更好的例子了。亨利·福特和他的经理们通过他们开创性的装配线彻底改变了生产。
And they influenced factories and working practices in countries all over the world. Another example of a business driving technological and social change is Amazon, which is increasing the number of its electric vehicles used for deliveries in Europe to over 10,000 by the end of this year, 2026. Now, on top of that, over 50% of Amazon deliveries now come with less packaging or sometimes no added packaging at all. It helps to avoid unnecessary waste and it makes recycling at home that much easier. Find out more at amazon.com.uk slash sustainability. Welcome back to the rest is history. We return with bombshell news from Antenabilly.
他们影响了世界各国的工厂和工作实践。另一个推动技术和社会变革的企业例子是亚马逊，到今年2026年底，它在欧洲用于配送的电动汽车数量将增加到超过10,000辆。此外，超过50%的亚马逊配送现在包装更少，有时甚至根本没有额外包装。这有助于避免不必要的浪费，并使在家回收变得更加容易。在amazon.com.uk/sustainability了解更多信息。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。我们带着来自安特卫普的重磅新闻回归。
work because it's the 17th of August 1585 and after a siege of 13 months. The richest city in this part of Europe, perhaps in all Europe, has finally surrendered to the Prince of Palmer. Actually, the end of the siege is not quite as bloody and gory as you might expect. So the Spanish are very well behaved, aren't they, in victory? And the terms, you said in the first half, Tom, that the terms that Palmer offers his defeated adversaries are often pretty generous, and they are in this case, aren't they? Yes. So Antwerp, which had been the great stronghold of Protestantism in the low countries,
工作，因为今天是1585年8月17日，经过13个月的围攻。欧洲这一地区，也许是整个欧洲最富有的城市，终于向帕尔马亲王投降了。实际上，围攻的结束并不像你预期的那样血腥和恐怖。所以西班牙人在胜利时表现得非常好，不是吗？而且条款，汤姆，你在上半部分说，帕尔马提供给被击败对手的条款通常相当慷慨，在这种情况下也是如此，对吧？是的。所以安特卫普，曾经是低地国家新教的伟大堡垒，
is formally restored to Catholicism. But as with Ghent, so in Antwerp, Protestants are allowed to leave the city if they want, and huge numbers do so. So probably around 60,000 people out of a total population of 100,000, so more than half. And this is actually a disaster for Antwerp because most of the people who are leaving, lots of them are bankers, merchants, the cutting edge of capitalism. And most of them head northwards to Holland, which is still the great nerve centre of the Dutch Revolt. And there they settle lots of them in a kind of new upstart hotspot for business. And this is a city called Amsterdam.
正式恢复了天主教。但就像根特一样，在安特卫普，新教徒如果愿意，可以离开这座城市，而且有大量的人这样做。所以可能在10万总人口中大约有6万人，也就是超过一半。这实际上对安特卫普来说是一场灾难，因为大多数离开的人，其中许多是银行家、商人，是资本主义的前沿。他们中的大多数人向北前往荷兰，那里仍然是荷兰起义的伟大神经中枢。在那里，他们中的许多人在一个商业的新兴热点定居。这就是一个叫阿姆斯特丹的城市。
And so the arrival of these exiles from Antwerp is really the making of Amsterdam as the great city of 17th century capitalism. Dutch Dishers will be pleased to be reminded that they basically owe their prominence and prosperity to the Belgians. So Anwerp has fallen and in England great gloom and foreboding, right? Absolutely. I mean, this is terrible, terrible news. And so three days later, after the fall of Antwerp on the 20th of August, a treaty is signed. between Elizabeth I and the Dutch rebels at a palace built by Henry VIII at a place called Non-Such in Surrey. And this is the first ever treaty signed by what will become the Dutch
所以这些来自安特卫普的流亡者的到来，真正造就了阿姆斯特丹作为17世纪资本主义伟大城市的地位。荷兰听众会很高兴被提醒，他们基本上将自己的显赫和繁荣归功于比利时人。所以安特卫普陷落了，英国陷入了巨大的阴霾和预感，对吧？绝对是。我的意思是，这是非常、非常糟糕的消息。所以三天后，在安特卫普陷落后的8月20日，签署了一项条约。在伊丽莎白一世和荷兰叛军之间，地点是在亨利八世在萨里郡一个叫“无双”（Non-Such）的地方建造的宫殿。这是未来荷兰共和国签署的第一份与外国势力的条约。
Republic with a foreign power. And by its terms, Elizabeth agrees to send an expeditionary force to the low countries to support Holland and the other rebel provinces. And this is to consist of 6,350 infantry and 1,000 cavalry. And amazingly, Elizabeth says, I will subsidise the cost of this. I mean, must have caused her agony to do that. And she chooses, as the commander of this expeditionary force, her old favourite, the Earl of Leicester. And because she doesn't entirely trust the Dutch, she obliges them to hand over three key ports to English garrisons to serve the English as what described as cautionary towns. So basically, these towns are kind of hostages. And they are the town of Brill, which commanded the mouth of the Great River Mass or the Mers,
根据条款，伊丽莎白同意派遣一支远征军到低地国家，以支持荷兰和其他叛乱省份。这支部队将由6350名步兵和1000名骑兵组成。令人惊讶的是，伊丽莎白说，我将补贴这笔费用。我的意思是，这一定让她感到痛苦。她选择了她最喜欢的老臣莱斯特伯爵作为这支远征军的指挥官。因为她并不完全信任荷兰人，她强迫他们将三个关键港口交给英国驻军，作为英国所谓的“警戒城镇”。所以基本上，这些城镇就像人质。它们是布里尔镇，它控制着马斯河或默兹河的河口，
if you're speaking in French, and Flushing and Ramekin, which are ports on an island just beyond the Scheldt estuary. And the reason for choosing these ports is that between them, it enables the English to control what goes in and goes out of the Shelt Estuary. Celt Estuary down towards Antwerp. So in other words, to throttle the ability of the Spanish to move by sea from Antwerp round the northern coast towards the rebel heartlands in Holland and Zeeland. And the guy who's going to be in charge of one of these, Flushing, is the star of today's episode. He's finally got his chance. He's finally got his opportunity to have a crack at the Spanish and write his name into the history books. And that is our friend Sir Philip Sidney. Yeah, so hooray for Sir Philip Sidney. And I think he owes this appointment to various factors. Favoritism, obviously. He's the nephew of Leicester, who has been appointed to the command of this expedition. He's put in a lot of hard work preparing the Treaty of Nonsuch. Basically, he'd spent all summer at the palace, kind of oiling the wheels.
如果你说法语的话，还有弗利辛恩和拉梅金，它们是斯海尔德河口外岛屿上的港口。选择这些港口的原因是，它们使英国人能够控制进出斯海尔德河口的东西。通往安特卫普的斯海尔德河口。换句话说，扼杀西班牙人从安特卫普通过海路绕过北部海岸向荷兰和泽兰叛军腹地移动的能力。而负责其中一个港口——弗利辛恩的人，正是今天这一集的主角。他终于得到了机会。他终于有机会去挑战西班牙人，并将自己的名字写进历史书。那就是我们的朋友菲利普·悉尼爵士。是的，为菲利普·悉尼爵士欢呼。我认为他将这次任命归功于各种因素。裙带关系，显然。他是莱斯特的侄子，莱斯特已被任命为这次远征的指挥官。他在准备《无双条约》方面做了大量艰苦的工作。基本上，他整个夏天都在宫殿里，算是润滑了轮子。
And the Dutch envoys had absolutely loved him. So they had saluted his wisdom, kindness and his other gifts. So it's all looking good for Sydney, but then in classic Elizabeth the first style, she starts to wobble. First of all, she hesitates over whether she actually wants Lester as Governor General. Does she really want him going to the low countries? And then to Sydney's absolute fury, she tells him, I don't want you going to flushing after all. She's changed her mind. And so he has the most massive strop. He storms off, he gets on his horse, and he says,
荷兰特使非常喜欢他。所以他们赞扬了他的智慧、善良和其他天赋。所以这对悉尼来说看起来一切都很好，但随后以经典的伊丽莎白一世风格，她开始动摇了。首先，她犹豫是否真的想要莱斯特担任总督。她真的想让他去低地国家吗？然后，令悉尼极其愤怒的是，她告诉他，我毕竟不希望你去弗利辛恩。她改变主意了。所以他发了最大的脾气。他冲了出去，骑上马，他说，
He gallops off to Plymouth. And the reason he goes to Plymouth is because Sydney knows that the low countries aren't the only place where there might be a chance for him to win glory for himself. There are other opportunities for would-be dashing young adventurers because all summer, when he wasn't negotiating with Dutch diplomats, Sydney had been helping Sir Francis Drake prepare for a massive expedition to the Indies. When I say massive, I mean, it is the largest English fleet. that has been raised for over a century. So some 20 ships, two of them provided by Elizabeth
他飞奔向普利茅斯。他去普利茅斯的原因是悉尼知道低地国家并不是他唯一可能赢得荣耀的地方。对于那些想成为风流倜傥的年轻冒险家来说，还有其他机会，因为整个夏天，当他不与荷兰外交官谈判时，悉尼一直在帮助弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士准备一次前往印度的远征。当我说是大规模时，我的意思是，这是超过一个世纪以来集结的最大规模的英国舰队。大约20艘船，其中两艘由伊丽莎白提供，
herself, including Drake's flagship, the Elizabeth Bonaventura. And the plan which has been drawn up by Drake, by the Privy Council, by Elizabeth herself, is for Drake to plunder as much gold and silver from the Spanish as he possibly can, and then use the proceeds to help fund the Dutch. So just as Philip has been targeting the English economy, the plan is that Drake will target the infrastructure that sustains Philip's supply of treasure. Right. And Lord Burley, who previously had been a bit of a Drake skeptic, I mean, he's right behind this. He thinks this is a brilliant plan. So he'd written to Walsingham about Philip, Philip II. Whilst his riches of the Indies continue, he thinketh he will be able with them to weary out all other princes. Those taken away himself will quickly fall.
包括德雷克的旗舰“伊丽莎白·博纳文图拉”号。由德雷克、枢密院和伊丽莎白本人制定的计划是，让德雷克尽可能多地从西班牙人那里掠夺黄金和白银，然后用这些收益来帮助资助荷兰人。所以正如腓力一直针对英国经济一样，计划是德雷克将针对维持腓力宝藏供应的基础设施。对。而之前对德雷克持怀疑态度的伯利勋爵，我的意思是，他完全支持这一点。他认为这是一个绝妙的计划。所以他写信给沃尔辛厄姆谈论腓力，腓力二世。只要印度的财富继续存在，他认为他将能够用它们来拖垮所有其他君主。那些被夺走，他自己很快就会倒下。
And I know by good means that he more feareth this action of Sir Francis than he ever did anything that have been attempted against him. So really interesting illustration of the sensitivity of people in the 16th century to the opportunities provided by economic warfare. I think people are kind of becoming more and more alert to this. So Sydney must be terribly excited about this. I mean, this really is a tremendous chance to win the kind of glory that he's been after. And when Drake's fleet sales out of Plymouth on the 14th of September, Drake is on the flagship and Sydney is there with him. I mean, it's potentially one of the great double acts in English history. Yeah, one of the great kind of buddy acts.
而且我通过很好的渠道知道，他比以往任何时候都更害怕弗朗西斯爵士的这次行动，超过了他曾经面对过的任何针对他的尝试。所以这真是对16世纪人们对经济战所提供机会的敏感性的一个非常有趣的说明。我认为人们对这一点越来越警觉。所以悉尼一定非常兴奋。我的意思是，这确实是一个赢得他一直追求的那种荣耀的绝佳机会。当德雷克的舰队于9月14日从普利茅斯起航时，德雷克在旗舰上，悉尼也和他在一起。我的意思是，这可能是英国历史上最伟大的双人组合之一。是的，一种伟大的伙伴关系。
But it doesn't happen because just as they're pulling out of Plymouth Sound in the Bonaventura, a rowing boat comes up the side of the boat with a message from the queen and she's changed her mind. And actually she does want Sydney to go to flushing. And so Sydney gets off the boat, gets into the rowing boat and goes back to London and ultimately to flushing. And obviously, Elizabeth is furious with Sydney. I mean, she doesn't like people rushing off without telling her. But she can't come down too hard on him because I think she has realised in his absence that actually, much to her annoyance, she does need him. So Lester, who she has by this point reappointed as Governor General of the low countries, He's busy recruiting troops around England and Wales, and so won't be able to leave for the low countries until December.
但它没有发生，因为就在他们从普利茅斯湾驶出“博纳文图拉”号时，一艘划艇靠在船边，带着女王的消息，她改变主意了。实际上，她确实希望悉尼去弗利辛恩。所以悉尼下了船，坐进划艇，回到了伦敦，最终去了弗利辛恩。显然，伊丽莎白对悉尼很愤怒。我的意思是，她不喜欢人们不告诉她就匆忙离开。但她不能对他太严厉，因为我想她在他的缺席中意识到，实际上，令她恼火的是，她确实需要他。所以莱斯特，她此时已经重新任命他为低地国家总督，他正忙于在英国和威尔士招募军队，所以直到12月才能离开前往低地国家。
Meanwhile, Palmer isn't waiting. He's advancing on all fronts, and the Dutch desperately need English support. And everyone, the Dutch, the English alike, are agreed. There is only the one man for the job. It has to be Sir Philip Sidney. And so Sydney goes to the low countries, which, as you said, Dominic, means that he misses his chance to go on an expedition to the new world. which he had, as you said, been very, very excited about. And so just to give a quick resume of the excitements he misses before we come to
与此同时，帕尔马并没有等待。他在各条战线上推进，荷兰人迫切需要英国的支持。每个人，荷兰人和英国人一样，都同意。只有一个人能胜任这项工作。那必须是菲利普·悉尼爵士。所以悉尼去了低地国家，正如你所说，多米尼克，这意味着他错过了去新世界远征的机会。正如你所说，他对此非常、非常兴奋。所以为了在他来到之前快速总结一下他错过的兴奋，
to what Sydney gets up to in the low countries, I mean, Drake heads southwards, and he has the most lovely time. So he turns up in Spain, and he extorts supplies out of a town in Galicia in northern Spain called Vigo, and he stays there for two weeks. And it's seen by Philip, I think quite correctly, as an absolutely massive humiliation that this English pirate has turned up and kind of replenished his supplies from Spanish stocks. Then Drake sweeps across the Atlantic, capturing and plundering Spanish strongholds as he goes. And when Drake captures Santo Domingo in what is now the Dominican Republic, he, you know, he's waiting
悉尼在低地国家做了什么，我的意思是，德雷克向南航行，他度过了一段非常愉快的时光。所以他出现在西班牙，并从西班牙北部加利西亚的一个叫维戈的城镇勒索了补给，他在那里待了两个星期。我认为腓力非常正确地将其视为一种绝对巨大的羞辱，这个英国海盗竟然出现了，并从西班牙的库存中补充了他的补给。然后德雷克横扫大西洋，一路掠夺西班牙的据点。当德雷克占领了现在多米尼加共和国的圣多明各时，他，你知道，他在等待
for the ransom and to force the Spanish to hurry up, he starts literally disassembling the city, brick by brick, until they've brought the gold. And then, you know, he's got the ransom, and then it's on to Cartagena. in Colombia, which he also captures. Again, he extorts a massive ransom. And this isn't a long expedition. He's back in Plymouth by the 22nd of July 1586. And actually, it's not quite as lucrative as Drake had been hoping. He doesn't manage to capture any treasure ships. But strategically, it is hugely significant because as he'd done before, he's able to highlight the pretty precarious nature of Spain's American Empire. And the result of this, in Europe,
赎金，为了迫使西班牙人加快速度，他开始字面意义上地拆除这座城市，一块砖一块砖地拆，直到他们带来黄金。然后，你知道，他拿到了赎金，然后前往卡塔赫纳。在哥伦比亚，他也占领了那里。同样，他勒索了巨额赎金。这不是一次长期的远征。他在1586年7月22日回到了普利茅斯。实际上，它并不像德雷克希望的那样有利可图。他没能捕获任何宝藏船。但在战略上，它是极其重要的，因为正如他之前所做的那样，他能够突出西班牙美洲帝国相当不稳定的本质。而这在欧洲的结果，
is to undermine Philip's credit with his bankers. And so the Pope and the Dukes of Florence and Savoy all refuse him alone when the news of Drake's expedition reaches them. And the Bank of Seville actually goes bust. And Burley is kind of cackling and rubbing his hands at this and says truly Sir Francis Drake is a fearful man to the king of Spain, which I think he is. So while Drake's been off sacking Cartagena and whatnot, what has Sir Philip Sidney doing? because he's been in the slightly more unglamorous surroundings of flushing on the... Yeah, an island off the Scheldestery. Yeah, so he's arrived there in mid-November, which is never really a great time to turn up to an island in the North Sea.
是削弱了腓力在银行家中的信誉。因此，当德雷克远征的消息传到教皇以及佛罗伦萨和萨伏伊公爵那里时，他们都拒绝借钱给他。塞维利亚银行实际上破产了。伯利对此咯咯笑着，搓着手说，弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士对西班牙国王来说确实是一个可怕的人，我认为他确实是。所以当德雷克去洗劫卡塔赫纳之类的地方时，菲利普·悉尼爵士在做什么？因为他一直待在弗利辛恩稍微不那么迷人的环境中……是的，斯海尔德河口外的一个岛屿。是的，所以他在11月中旬到达那里，这从来都不是去北海岛屿的好时机。
It's completely miserable. And when he lands, he has to walk three miles through mud before he can reach the port itself. And he wrote to Lester, as dirtier walk as ever poor governor entered his charge with all. Lester himself arrives in flushing three weeks later. and he's greeted there by Sydney, by the two sons of William the Silent, and by bonfires made, and I quote, after the Dutch manor, which is to fix great pitch barrels on the tops of high poles and then to fire them. Wow. So Leicester has a better arrival than Sydney had done, and the pair of them then head off in triumphal manner via Delft to the Hague, where Lester then leaves Sydney to finalise the precise details of his role and status in the low countries. And Sydney is very ambitious for his uncle and he goes well beyond the governor's rebate and he secures a post for Lester which implies that Elizabeth is in fact sovereign over the low countries, which is exactly what Elizabeth had not wanted him to do.
这完全是悲惨的。当他登陆时，他必须在泥泞中走三英里才能到达港口本身。他写信给莱斯特，这是可怜的总督承担责任以来走过的最肮脏的路。莱斯特本人三周后到达弗利辛恩。悉尼、威廉沉默者的两个儿子迎接了他，还有用“荷兰方式”制作的篝火，我引用一下，就是在高杆顶上固定巨大的沥青桶，然后点燃它们。哇。所以莱斯特的到来比悉尼好，他们两人随后以凯旋的方式经由代尔夫特前往海牙，莱斯特在那里让悉尼最终确定他在低地国家角色和地位的精确细节。悉尼对他的叔叔非常有野心，他远远超出了总督的权限，他为莱斯特争取了一个职位，这意味着伊丽莎白实际上是低地国家的主权者，这正是伊丽莎白不希望他做的。
And I think the reason that Sydney does this is that he's aware that Lester needs to seem as prestigious to the Dutch rebels and indeed to the Spanish as possible if he's going to be able to play an effective role in the coming war. Obviously, when Elizabeth gets the news, she is furious. And they have a massive row. And I think for the Dutch, it's a bit like watching Mommy and Daddy have a kind of quarrel. It's very awkward for all concerned. And from this point on, essentially everything goes downhill for Lester. Because it turns out that his qualities, amazingly, he's a very arrogant aristocrat, turn out not to be those of a natural diplomat.
我认为悉尼这样做的原因是，他意识到如果莱斯特想在即将到来的战争中发挥有效作用，他必须在荷兰叛军甚至西班牙人面前显得尽可能显赫。显然，当伊丽莎白得到消息时，她非常愤怒。他们大吵了一架。我认为对于荷兰人来说，这有点像看着爸爸妈妈吵架。这对所有相关人员来说都非常尴尬。从这一点开始，莱斯特的情况基本上走下坡路。因为事实证明，他的品质，令人惊讶的是，他是一个非常傲慢的贵族，结果并不是一个天生的外交官。
So he's very, very dogmatic about religious matters. He's a hardcore Puritan. This means that he gets on very well with the hardcore Calvinists, Puritans in Holland, but it alienates the mass of the people in the kind of the rebel cause in the low countries who aren't hardcore Calvinists. They're what are called Politique, people who are essentially happy to live and let live to a degree. This isn't what Lester's about at all. Then in June 1586, he executes a Dutch commander who'd surrendered a fortress to the Spanish
所以他在宗教问题上非常、非常教条。他是一个铁杆清教徒。这意味着他与荷兰的铁杆加尔文主义者、清教徒相处得很好，但这疏远了低地国家叛乱事业中的大众，他们不是铁杆加尔文主义者。他们被称为“政治派”（Politique），基本上是乐于在一定程度上和平共处的人。这根本不是莱斯特的风格。然后在1586年6月，他处决了一名向西班牙人投降了堡垒的荷兰指挥官，
and again, this is not the kind of thing that the Dutch do. They think it's a terrible thing for Lester to have done. Right. And even while he's executing Dutch commanders for surrendering fortresses to the Spanish, Lester himself is kind of sitting on his hands, refusing to go on the offensive. And even Sydney
同样，这不是荷兰人会做的事情。他们认为莱斯特这样做是一件可怕的事情。对。即使在他因为向西班牙人投降堡垒而处决荷兰指挥官时，莱斯特本人也袖手旁观，拒绝发动进攻。甚至悉尼
is starting to despair by the summer of 1586. And he writes to Lester saying, The enemy stirs of every side and your side must not be idle. For if it be, it quickly looseth reputation. And of course, in the background, there is Elizabeth who is, you know, she's back to her old penny-pinching ways.
到1586年夏天也开始绝望了。他写信给莱斯特说，敌人四面出击，你这边绝不能闲着。因为如果闲着，它很快就会失去声誉。当然，背景中还有伊丽莎白，你知道，她又回到了她那精打细算的旧习惯。
She's refusing to send money to Sydney so that he can pay his garrison in flushing. And again, Sydney is in despair. If the Queen pay not her soldiers, she must lose her garrisons. There is no doubt thereof. And so in short, everyone is incredibly annoyed with everyone else. Elizabeth is quarreling with Leicester, the English are quarreling with the Dutch. Sydney's quarreling with pretty much everyone else. He makes sure that people appreciate none of it is his fault.
她拒绝给悉尼寄钱，这样他就无法支付他在弗利辛恩的驻军费用。悉尼再次陷入绝望。如果女王不支付士兵工资，她就必须失去她的驻军。毫无疑问。所以简而言之，每个人都对其他人感到非常恼火。伊丽莎白在和莱斯特吵架，英国人在和荷兰人吵架。悉尼在和几乎所有其他人吵架。他确保人们明白这一切都不是他的错。
So he writes, no man living shall be able to say the fault is in me. I mean, I think you can perhaps see why Elizabeth finds him a bit annoying. Yeah. But the thing is, this is all a surprise to me, because I've always thought of Sir Philip Sidney as this tremendous hero. You know, schools are named after him. Yeah, his name is written into the kind of annals of English patriotic legend. If they're just all squabbling with each other and behaving badly, why is he so admired?
所以他写道，没有活着的人能说错在我。我的意思是，我想你也许能明白为什么伊丽莎白觉得他有点烦人。是的。但问题是，这一切对我来说都很惊讶，因为我一直认为菲利普·悉尼爵士是一位了不起的英雄。你知道，学校以他的名字命名。是的，他的名字被写进了英国爱国传奇的编年史中。如果他们只是在互相争吵，表现得很糟糕，为什么他如此受人钦佩？
Because I think as with Byron, as with Che Guevara, he's going to die young and he's going to serve as a martyr for his cause. Okay. And that essentially is why Sydney becomes a kind of superstar to Protestant Europe. And so how does this happen? So in September 1586, Lester finally goes on the attack and he besieges and captures a Spanish-held town called Doysburg on the eastern front. on the eastern flank of rebel-held territory. And if you're a fan of Dutch geography, it's in the province of Gelderland,
因为我认为就像拜伦一样，就像切·格瓦拉一样，他会英年早逝，他会成为他事业的烈士。好的。这基本上就是为什么悉尼成为新教欧洲的超级巨星。那么这是怎么发生的呢？所以1586年9月，莱斯特终于发动进攻，他围攻并占领了一个叫杜伊斯堡的西班牙控制的城镇，在东部前线。在叛军控制领土的东翼。如果你是荷兰地理的粉丝，它在海尔德兰省，
which is to the southeast of the Zyda Sea. And Sydney rides out with Lester. You know, hooray, brilliant. He's got kind of feathers in his helmet. He's got beautiful armour. He's having a brilliant time. War at last. It seems to be going well.
在须德海的东南部。悉尼和莱斯特一起骑马出征。你知道，万岁，太棒了。他的头盔上有羽毛。他有漂亮的盔甲。他度过了一段美好的时光。终于开战了。看起来进展顺利。
And Lester is buoyed by the sense that things are going his way. And so he moves on to his next target, which is a town called Zutphen, so the South Fen. And Palmer is very anxious to relieve this town. And so he sends a force of 5,000 men to its rescue on the 22nd of September. There's a big battle. There are lots of kind of heroic cavalry charges. The English acquit themselves very well.
莱斯特受到事情正朝着他希望的方向发展的鼓舞。所以他转向了他的下一个目标，一个叫聚特芬（Zutphen）的城镇。帕尔马非常焦虑地想要解救这个城镇。所以他在9月22日派出一支5000人的部队去救援。有一场大战。有很多英雄般的骑兵冲锋。英国人表现得非常好。
However, they are unable to stop the Spanish from entering Zutphen. And that basically is, that's the end of that. So it's a battle that I think no one would. remember, had Sir Philip Sidney not sustained a very serious wound in the course of it? Now I said that there are these kind of dramatic cavalry charges. Sidney'd written in all of them, there were three in all. So the first time he'd, you know, drawn his sword, charged, hurrah, gone through the Spanish lines and then returned. The second time his horse had been shot from under him. He got another horse again, very gallant,
然而，他们无法阻止西班牙人进入聚特芬。这基本上就是结局了。所以这是一场我认为如果没有菲利普·悉尼爵士在其中受了重伤，没人会记得的战斗。现在我说有这些戏剧性的骑兵冲锋。悉尼参加了所有这些，总共有三次。所以第一次他，你知道，拔出剑，冲锋，万岁，穿过西班牙防线，然后返回。第二次他的马被从他身下射中。他又换了一匹马，非常勇敢，
very heroic. The third time again, he'd ridden through the enemy lines, but then when he's turning to ride back to the English positions, he gets hit above his left knee by a musket ball. And as Lester wrote in appalled tones later, it was a very dangerous wound, the bone being broken pieces. So Lester is very anxious for his nephew and his heir, of course, puts him in a barge, has him carried down the river to Arnhem, 20 miles south of Zupon. And in Arnhem, surgeons operate on the wound. But unfortunately, their attempt to extract the bullet only makes things worse and gangrene sets in and to quote sir philip presently gave this severe doom upon himself that it was inward mortification and a welcome messenger of death and sure enough on the afternoon of the 17th of october 1586 sir philip sidney died at the tender age of 31 and it's a wretched unhappy end rather like byron's end was wretched and unhappy and in his dying hour as Sir Philip Sidney mourned that all things in my former life have been vain, vain, vain.
非常英勇。第三次他又骑马穿过敌方防线，但当他转身骑回英国阵地时，他的左膝上方被一颗火枪弹击中。正如莱斯特后来以震惊的语气写道，这是一个非常危险的伤口，骨头被碎裂了。所以莱斯特非常担心他的侄子和继承人，当然，把他放在一艘驳船上，让他顺流而下到阿纳姆，在聚特芬以南20英里处。在阿纳姆，外科医生对伤口进行了手术。但不幸的是，他们试图取出子弹只会让事情变得更糟，坏疽开始蔓延，引用菲利普爵士的话，他立刻对自己做出了严厉的判决，这是内在的坏死，是死亡的欢迎使者，果然在1586年10月17日下午，菲利普·悉尼爵士在31岁的花样年华去世了，这是一个悲惨、不幸的结局，就像拜伦的结局一样悲惨和不幸，在临终时刻，菲利普·悉尼爵士哀叹，我前生的一切都是虚空，虚空，虚空。
But this is not how his uncle, the Earl of Lester, sees it. And Lester may have been irascible, incompetent, arrogant. But one thing he does know is how to create a martyr. And so Lester ensures that Sydney's funeral cortege is very slow, very somber, very stately. and it processes from Arnhem to the sea and thence to London. And in London, his coffin is carried to St. Paul's Cathedral by 14 men. He's accompanied by the Lord Mayor, by 300 Londoners in full armour, and by a page riding Sydney's warhorse, trailing a broken lance.
但这并不是他的叔叔莱斯特伯爵眼中的样子。莱斯特可能易怒、无能、傲慢。但他确实知道如何制造一位烈士。所以莱斯特确保悉尼的葬礼队伍非常缓慢、非常阴沉、非常庄严。它从阿纳姆游行到海边，然后到伦敦。在伦敦，他的棺材由14个人抬到圣保罗大教堂。他由市长、300名全副武装的伦敦人以及一名骑着悉尼战马、拖着断矛的侍从陪同。
So shades, perhaps, of the funeral of JFK. And the streets were so thronged with people that the mourners had scarce room to pass. in death, Sydney becomes what he had yearned to be all his life, a hero to every English Protestant and indeed to every Protestant in Christendom. And for Elizabeth and her PR team, her propaganda team, this must be a tremendous coup because it happens at precisely the point when it looks as though the storm clouds of war are moving over the English Channel towards our own beloved country. They are about to break.
所以，也许是肯尼迪葬礼的影子。街道上挤满了人，哀悼者几乎没有空间通过。在死亡中，悉尼成为了他一生渴望成为的人，每一位英国新教徒，实际上是基督教世界每一位新教徒的英雄。对于伊丽莎白和她的公关团队、她的宣传团队来说，这一定是一次巨大的政变，因为它发生得恰好在战争风暴云似乎正从英吉利海峡向我们自己亲爱的国家移动的时候。它们即将爆发。
They are about to break, aren't. they, because, I mean, all of this has been, it's been building and building over the episodes of this series over the last few years. And the storm is, what is it? I mean, is it pouring with, with rain over the dikes of the low countries? Surely there must be some metaphor you can employ here, Tom. Yes, the storm is breaking over the, the dyes of the low countries and the rumbling of thunder can be heard on the south coast of England. I think that's definitely the way to frame it. But of course, even as these war clouds are building, war is brewing as well amid the shadows. And so in our next and final episode, we will be returning to that dimension of shadow,
它们即将爆发，不是吗？因为，我的意思是，这一切都是，在过去几年的这一系列剧集中一直在建立和建立。风暴是，它是什么？我的意思是，它是在低地国家的堤坝上倾盆大雨吗？汤姆，你肯定能在这里使用一些隐喻。是的，风暴正在低地国家的堤坝上爆发，在英国南海岸可以听到雷声。我认为这绝对是构建它的方式。但当然，即使这些战争云正在聚集，战争也在阴影中酝酿。所以，在我们的下一集也是最后一集中，我们将回到那个阴影维度，
to a world of secrets and of spies and conspiracies. And in particular, we will be tracking someone who has been absolutely central to this series, but who until now has been a largely off-stage presence. And Dominic, a personal favourite of yours, one of your great heroines, someone who in all kinds of ways actually was the precise opposite of Sir Philip Sidney. So she's a woman, not a man, a Catholic, not a Protestant, and she's an aging prisoner, not a youthful, dashing courtier. And we are talking, of course, about Mary Queen of Scots.
一个充满秘密、间谍和阴谋的世界。特别是，我们将追踪一个在本系列中一直处于核心地位，但直到现在一直是一个很大程度上在幕后存在的人。多米尼克，你个人的最爱，你伟大的女英雄之一，一个在各方面实际上与菲利普·悉尼爵士完全相反的人。所以她是一个女人，不是男人，一个天主教徒，不是新教徒，她是一个年迈的囚犯，不是一个年轻、风流倜傥的朝臣。我们谈论的当然是苏格兰女王玛丽。
Mary Queen of Scots and her appointment with the executioner all to come in the next episode. Now, if you're a member of the Rest is History Club, if you're a member of our own expeditionary force to bring the gospel of history to the low countries, then you'll be able to hear that episode right now. And if you want to join them, if you want to join us in the dikes and whatever they are, the Polders of the Netherlands. Love a Polder. If you want to join us, then head to the rest is history.com and sign up.
苏格兰女王玛丽和她与刽子手的约定，所有这些都将在下一集中出现。现在，如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，如果你是我们为了将历史福音带到低地国家而组建的远征军的一员，那么你现在就能听到那一集了。如果你想加入他们，如果你想加入我们在堤坝和无论它们是什么，荷兰的圩田（Polder）。喜欢圩田。如果你想加入我们，那么前往therestisistory.com并注册。
And that is, of course, the only way that you'll be able to get this cornucopia of unbelievable benefits. The other thing you probably want to do, this is a revelation. I imagine to a lot of listeners, something I've never heard before. But we have a free newsletter with all kinds of incredible literary treats. So there are interviews and there are articles and there are book extracts and all kinds of fun things that you can't get anywhere else. and again you go to our website, you sign up, and then you get this every week, and you just, you will be beside yourself.
当然，这是你获得这种令人难以置信的好处宝库的唯一途径。你可能想做的另一件事，这是一个启示。我想对很多听众来说，这是我从未听说过的。但我们有一个免费的时事通讯，里面有各种令人难以置信的文学享受。所以有采访，有文章，有书籍摘录，还有各种你在其他任何地方都得不到的有趣东西。同样，你访问我们的网站，你注册，然后你每周都会收到这个，你只会，你会欣喜若狂。
It's genuinely life-changing. So on that bombshell, we will be back next time with Mary Queen of Scots. Goodbye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这确实是改变生活的。所以带着这个重磅炸弹，我们下次将带着苏格兰女王玛丽回来。再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。